hi my name is Emmanuel Garces I'm from
Mexico and I work for Wolfram I will
talk about Geographic visualization
the content of the talk essentially is a
very brief overview of Geographics
Francisco is going to talk about this in
more detail tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. in the
same place and that covers some
primitives that we can use with
Geographics and some functions we we
have for visualized geographic features
then I'm going to talk about geo
histogram that new function in version
11 then how we can combine or interact
with different visualization functions
using show and finally some applications
so as you probably know Geographics with
now input show was our local location so
okay let me see it's okay
so for this case evaluating this here in
Champaign Anita was a map of our current
location we can also show a map of the
world by typing the string world and of
course there's there are other options
we can set into the this function but
tomorrow there will be more details
about this we can also show a map of the
unit United States or probably again
just City by inputting it with an entity
right so this is basic basically what
geographic those and we have a different
damages options so it's just very brief
showing of geographic that francisco's
going to talk tomorrow more in detail
but it's the base of every geographic
plot that we have so there is an example
using different options for Geographics
as you can see we can set the geo
projection we can set the geo background
and in this case we are showing just the
contour we can set on enough geo grid
lines and change the scale bar this case
is Imperial we can put some geo markers
using these rappers for instance in this
case we are showing London City so there
are different options for geographic
that as I said Francisco is going to
talk about more in detail tomorrow
there are primitive we can use and put
things over there Geographics plot dot i
mean bread talked about one of them geo
pad for instance we have a pad from New
York City that's the distance and that's
the direction right and we can specify
different kinds of paths another
primitive we have is geo circle in this
case we are showing a circle centered in
this lat/long position and we specify a
radius of three thousand kilometers so
as you can see it doesn't seems like a
perfect circle right because of the
projection and okay we are showing the
the whole world the circle in the whole
world so similarly we have Jew disc that
essentially it's the same like a circle
but it's a disc
cholera threat there is another
primitive called geo visible region in
this case we are showing we feed this
primitive with geo position and show us
what it's the region of the world that
it's visible from that point in this
case the position of the International
Space Station people's jaw position this
case you can see there are four numbers
because one of them is at the time but
no matter of that we have a lot long and
the height of the International Space
Station and then we see what's the
observable area of
from that point we have he'll do
hemisphere showing us what the foreign
from one point for instance here Mexico
City
what's the hemisphere that we can see
it's entering the the the earth into
this point so this area is what's
observable from central Mexico City in
the in the world we have a night
Hemisphere and a hemisphere
you can see both of them are similarly
because you know that there is the great
part is the night and the white parrots
day the day I took this I evaluated this
yesterday like at 3:00 p.m. so it's like
about the same right now probably when
1/2
- aware a difference so those are
primitives that you can we can use I
mean in Geographics right besides the
primitives we also have some Juba so
certain functions probably you you do
know some of them we have Julie's plot
that essentially is plotting different
entities that have NGO entities for
instance we are showing here some
countries in Asia let me change the size
of this okay so Julie's plot with the
list of entities show us the the
entities in this case countries those
could be cities or another entities
major entities or we can fit
the the function with sometimes serious
right so we have a time combined it with
geo entity and we can use joint to show
probably a path or a travel right this
is one of the functions we have for your
ability utilization I'm not going to
focus in in this particular area I'm
just showing a brief overview of them
the other function we have is really
invaluable OTT that allow us to show
gradients along with value so in this
case we are showing different countries
in Europe and some values for each
country and then is showing us the the
color for for each for each value right
it's quite similar to you histogram but
you know your histogram is going to do
things more automatically then I had
really three envelope that okay so
that's a very brief introduction to
[Music]
primitives and functions we have we have
more primitives but I just showed some
of the main relatives because there are
a lot of them okay now let's start with
you historian this function is
introduced in version at 12 now I mean
11 we don't have 12 bit okay I just put
this line to change the plot theme
because the default colors for your
histogram
probably are not good for the
presentation so I'm I'm just showing
this plot theme so that's why I put this
line the basic idea of you histogram is
we have a set of latitude and longitude
pairs of points of course in the in the
world for instance we have a table of 30
points of random numbers between some
range and then we're going to show the
histogram on the map of those points as
you can see the default meaning is a
spread set our polygons so we have we
have polygons average area where there
are points so what we do you can see the
number here they're there for number 4
points here there 1 point here and so on
so the default behavior of the histogram
disease but we can we have different
specifications for data not just pairs
of latitude and longitude list we could
have a new position object of many
points in this case there are 30 points
there the blood bounds long rounds etc
etc so we can feed your histogram with
an object like this and the behavior
will be the same the other kind of input
we can feed this function is by using
entity class in this example we are
showing the distribution of skyscrapers
around the world
so you can see the first argument of
your histogram is data and in this case
the the this argument is an entity class
so the second argument I going to talk
about later is going to be the quiet
I mean how company means do we want at
the white of the plot we we want to show
everything in the world and of course
shall an automatic legends to see how
colors are associated with accountings
so you can see cuz there's a lot there
are a lot of buildings in this area that
seem this is new job right we have well
we have four in Mexico City Europe and
so on so the main idea of this is that
we can easily feed this function with
objects that we already have like entity
classes instead of taking the positions
of every entity that has coordinates the
histogram does it automatically we can
also feed your histogram with
associations and this means that we can
associate every entity with positions
like countries and then we make an
association to any value in this case we
have the entity and population so your
histogram is not going to be counting
itself instead of that it's going to
make the sum of
or accumulate every value that we have
for each entity and then applied the
bringing processing so we can see here
are the countries in Europe and then we
can see areas where there are more
population than others okay so this is
interesting because we can associate
different values okay so we can use
weighted data in this case I'm using a
function to generate what the data
associating some entities in this case
those are the largest city of United
States along with their population this
you know this trouble this function
generators the weighted data for the
cities and populations and as the
example we showed before we are showing
areas where there are more people so
right there's more people here or people
here and less people here now we are
only showing these hexagons I'm going to
talk about different kinds of winning
later okay
[Music]
so we talked about data and the ways we
can fit the histogram function using
different data now I'm going to talk
about the specification of of bringing
as I said the default behavior of your
histogram is use this hexagon tilings
it's a you know is one of the more
popular way of filling some space but we
have different ways of filling some area
like rectangles so in this case I'm
using data from Japan I I don't remember
what was the data I think it's I'm not
sure if it's the population of Japan or
just run the random points at Japan but
I'm using a rectangle bringing
specification okay yeah we also have
triangles okay now we can specify them
the number of being means that we would
like to have at the white of the plot so
if we set 15 means it means that there
are going to be 15 happens at the
columns because we have here Hawaii from
here to here there are 15 and not okay
we also can specify a total number of
Bin's we want to have in this case we
have 10 rectangles right we could have
any number of orphans okay we could use
quantity to specify the size of the bins
in this case we are using
hexagons of diameter of 500 kilometers
so the the diameter of each bin is 500
kilometers we can mix it you bet using a
different figure for the winning we can
also use you know triangles by 500 times
1000 kilometers and also we can use an
unit of squared area like Icarus so in
this case we're showing the distribution
of buildings in New York by using bins
of 1000 degrees right okay
another building methods include so
there are methods that are already in
the I mean academic area like storages
by the way this is default this is the
default meaning for for the function
Scott and fin Friedman the icon is right
okay
now another bin specification is the we
can use to identify name in this case we
are using the country's for for winnings
we can specify explicit list of bins in
this case we want their states of
friends as bins we can specify a
function that essentially takes the the
beans as an argument and
and then you can choose a different
meaning in this case if there are more
than 10 points I'm going to use the
administrative division for France in
this case States but if if there are not
more than 10 points I'm going to use an
automatic one so we can use a function
to specify the demeaning we have
specified a specification of height
essentially we just have accountings I'm
sure this example because those are
points are robbery the world in
homogeneous distribution only to show
that these are counting these are
probability
these are intensity that depends on the
area as you can see the colors change
because the area and near the poles is
different and we have a probability
density function as well for instance
this is the usual plot of the histogram
but if I use the intensity height
specification then we have a different
behavior because the area of each bin is
different okay we have options different
options okay you know changing colors
[Music]
okay changing the background of the
essentially those are the same options
for Geographics we can use different geo
projections right we can use your range
plot style of course different themes
you can see
and we can also well dynamic your
efficacy orderly have heard about it we
can I'm going ahead because there is
almost time we can use show to combine
different plots for instance we are
using here
Julie's plot and then some points at
some Asian countries then I do histogram
for those countries and then I'm going
to use show to combine all of the three
plots that we have finally some
applications for instance here we have
the density of trees in Champaign
Illinois we can use dynamic Geographics
to interact with this so so we can see
where the trees were where the green
areas we can see the distribution of
earthquakes around the world finally
okay you can use as I said with the data
and showing the locations of breweries
in the United States that finally we
will get a plot like this showing points
where the breweries are and the
densities of each brewery so think
that's in an interesting application and
that's an
you